hey guys I'm back and ready to talk
about some new releases we're in July
which means we're actually a bit short
untitled right now but lucky for anyone
interested in some sick mech
first-person shooters Hawkin is coming
out to save the day this was originally
on pc but now it's coming to ps4 and
xbox one you're a mech pilot with more
than 30 mex at your disposal each with a
different fighting style and this ranges
from assassin too heavy to tank you can
customize your mex as you play across
six game modes and nine environments
sounds pretty rata well what if I told
you this shiz is free right now with a
digital download or you can grab the
founders bundle for about 50 bucks on
the Xbox store that gives you some sweet
skins and taunts and some money to buy
other mechs but it's up to you this is
coming to ps4 on the 8th so there's
really no reason not to try this bad boy
also this week uh yeah let's see that
again it sets the tone right away with
what this game is about carmageddon max
damage revives the points for
pedestrians Destruction Derby style car
game series you might remember it on
steam but now it's on ps4 and Xbox one
carmageddon max damage offers campaign
races head-to-head car crusher and death
race modes the gameplay is pretty arcade
the arenas are full of various kinds of
power-ups and total there's over 90
actually and the game has the most maps
and vehicles in the history of the
series but really you're just gonna run
around murdering people so have fun it's
out on the 8th also this week we get the
beautiful but deadly Banner Saga too for
those of you who are new to the banner
saga this is a stunning tactical
role-playing game set in a Viking like
fantasy setting with hand-drawn
animations ed Tran reviewed this on PC
he gave it an 8 out of 10 saying like
the original game the banner saga to
leaves you holding your breath
completely invested in the world its
inhabitants and their struggles
anxiously eager for more this is now
coming to ps4 on the first and X
one on the fifth also this week you and
a ragtag crew of survivors explore the
surrounding Islands as you hunt for the
resources you'll need to upgrade your
ship and make your escape lost see is an
explorative action adventure taking
place by the Bermuda Triangle where
you'll explore millions of procedurally
generated islands and encounter an array
of deadly traps and dangerous critters
does anything on this godforsaken Island
help you it was only supposed to be a
three-hour tour this is on pc ps4 and
xbox one on the fifth for 15 bucks
finally fury is all about the tension of
one-on-one fights against deadly
adversary this hack and slash gives you
the ability to slash with your sword
shoot with your gun dodge and parry
that's it to take down guardians who are
no joke by the way this is all bass
bottles folks nothing else if you like
fighting games like devil may cry you
might find this interesting and you can
grab it on PC and ps4 on the 5th that's
it this week do you remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings sometimes they change and I'll
see you guys again next week
you